so i'm hyped up on it because i that's
all i watched growing
up was tennis yeah what happened between
you and
christa right to it
right because i i don't buy listen
nobody buys it
and and i'm gonna get the truth so
here's the deal yeah
i don't buy that it was like a you know
a mutual you know
departure i mean i believe there was a
blowout
um if we were to call it a band outside
of wham what would it be
outside a whale that's hard it's gonna
be a duo um
oh simon and garfunkel oh wow was that a
bad breakup or paul simon
you're [ __ ] paul simon so um i don't
know if it was a bad breakup but uh
i'm sure uh garfunkel was sad about it
yeah
because paul had you know i mean a big
career yeah garfunkel
i don't know what he did maybe he though
those pics for his hair you know
maybe he could start a company or
something he had a beautiful unique film
yeah so what happened um
yeah we had an amicable split no it
wasn't there we go it's completely
amicable
there's no way it works we were just
about to pop we had just gotten
started that's what it is i'll tell you
why i know it's not
okay i'll tell you what i know it's not
because it's one of those things where
it's like
um let's suppose let's go back to wham
right
so i don't know wham's career right but
i'm sure they got together
or whatever they did you know i mean but
they also played you know what i mean
and
right before like a big major label was
about to sign them them breaking up
like the day before so i believe that
there was some sort of
fight or blowout i also believe
that it wasn't your fault i believe it
was chris stefano's fault garfunkel
it was scar focus fault right
and um i believe that there was some
there's some bad blood
now let me let me ask you something you
don't have to get specific you don't
think it's specific because i know
i feel like an international war enough
doesn't know this glass make it
it looks like the hague in here yeah
yeah so what i feel like i'm a bosnian
war criminal
yeah i'm gonna drink poe remember when
he drinks the poison and kills himself
yeah yeah yeah
no the uh some other uh macedonian or
another country
yeltsin is alive yeah he likes vodka
is he still alive yeltsin i know what
you're trying to do i'm trying to
deflect
i'm trying to help you out i know the
warcraft where's your mom pete i need to
play tennis
are your panties wet yeah so um i'm
sorry for
ask i have to because you know it's one
of those things where
when i heard about it through the
grapevine it kind of
hurt me i heard i heard you lost sleep
over here i did very absolutely um
and so was it just stefano's fault
uh stefano i don't know yeah didn't
bother them
yeah memorize it um i no i can't i can't
i don't
you know we we we did a last episode it
was great
it was we we were ha we were both happy
we hugged we're still very good friends
to this day
i don't think you are conscious
uncoupling we did it yeah was it was a
conscious uncoupling let me ask you this
yeah he's in town you know is he here
[Laughter]
he'll be on this program yeah two weeks
so that's what my anxiety attack is
about
starbucks so what i'm asking is is that
you know if you guys are okay you guys
great friends
yeah he's here i bet you money you won't
see him
while you're in l.a no no no we're going
to meet up and play pickleball uh
have you seen that sport by the way yeah
yeah it's in austin
he's busy he's doing a show no that's
impossible
because i'll tell you i think he's gonna
do another whiskey ginger episode
eight or nine he texts me every day he
texts me every day when can i be on
tiger belly yeah
right so he's itching right to do
something right
to hang out right so i know that there's
some bad blood there and i'm i'm asking
you
right this is going to kill him that you
had me on first or him
yes no
uh i mean in fact i've ignored his calls
because um well let me just say
something about the stefano
he's calling the wrong person he's not
the guy to call to get on this podcast
you got to call
george directly and i think that's what
you did probably yes i called george and
we forwarded to gilbert and the spanish
guy i have no idea
he'll never relay the message to anyone
yeah so you know when i read it it's
like i always think um
i want to do your podcast i always go
yeah good idea and then i just
that's it yeah yeah so um
just let's let's not you know i mean
yeah i just want a brief
answer from you and then we could just
move on so creatively
i i feel like you know we fulfilled
our mission together that god put
together our chemistry was rhythmic it
was from the stars it was
it was it was incredible it was
inexplicable yeah it was incredible
and i was very musical and um i believe
he wanted more money
i believe i believe he's he said wait a
second
we were making pretty good money i know
we were about to make really good money
i know
and i believe that he kind of went you
know what i believe
that i deserve don't what do you
you think i'm getting in trouble for
this no no no i want to i
do you think i get nervous
with these kinds of things because it's
like you know friendships are delicate
and friendships and work are delicate
it's a delicate balance
it's business and i also just think
you're about to make a peter saterra
reference that would break my heart
okay so what i'm saying though too is
that if andrew santino
right you know if him and i if he said
some [ __ ] like
listen buddy i do most of the work um
you know you're 50
of the thing but it's like you don't do
the legwork so i think
i think i deserve this amount you
deserve that amount right because we
split 50 50.
right i think that i would have had i've
had
i would have had a really big problem
with that
nothing like that happened why did you
raise your hand
huh that was kind of weird
that was weird i don't know yeah i don't
know
i don't know what i'm doing here yeah
all right so nothing like that no
you're just saying you're just saying it
was creative differences uh
yeah i you know uh he's over here now
he's here for a couple months
he started a podcast with sal which is
great hey babe you should check out i
started one called long days we went in
with just solo solo it's going good it's
off to a great start and his
his hey babe with sal is doing great
sal's a big comedy star
right does arenas but because let me say
something though because
he did start one with somebody else
so the excuse of like him going i want
to go solo i just want to you know
create my own franchise and my own
market so he does you know he wants to
partner up with somebody right
so that would to me would mean sorry i
know you're looking at me in a weird way
but that would to me
i'm sorry i apologize i just have to
just finish my train of thought thank
you right sure
right there we go all right so there you
guys are right old days
yeah that's us all right so i just want
to let you know that i you know you can
say what you want to say
and i and i don't believe you right um i
believe that there was bad blood
i believe that it was his you know man
because i know he gives people covered
he gave scent he almost killed my friend
he almost killed him was killed my
friend by one of my best friends santino
yeah and also must kill us right
yeah so it's like you know i gave you he
gave you guys all covered no but he
didn't have it he brought a covenant he
brought a mexican
riddled person oh right right brought a
mexican guide to the studio right right
he's banging yeah yeah yeah donnie's
[ __ ] right who's i heard he's doing a
podcast with as well um
yeah on the side so um but he didn't get
covered which is amazing because he's
gotten
every other venereal disease yeah i feel
like kovid showed up and was like
there's two it was like an elevator that
was too full
and then i got it from akash yeah so
when you got it when did you get it
i got it uh november classic class of
2012 did it get you good or was it
got me good yeah i had the gi version
and uh i had to go to the hospital and
then it was just mostly anxiety after
that so
when you went to the i just had a
daughter and no my breathing was fine i
did have double pneumonia
but i was [ __ ] everything out i was
vomiting everything
and i missed my little daughter she was
three weeks old at the time oh so it was
it was all [ __ ] up and i was
quarantining in our studio
to stay away from my mother-in-law and
wife and stuff wow so how long did it
last
it was the whole thing was about two
three weeks so then
yeah and then so everything got a little
chaotic with hyenas he had started the
podcast with cell
uh i found out about it later and uh
that's it that's it that's it you missed
you missed it
no no that's it what are you talking
about i found out later you can
interpret that as i had covered i got it
should we rewind that how you said that
he didn't honk the horn
wow i just got it he
[ __ ] left you when you were sick he
didn't honk the horn
starting it with someone else bro oh my
god my eyes are burning so
check this out all right i didn't say
that i didn't say that you guys are
reading into it that's what it is
bastard will be your interpreter i
didn't say it so
so there was take me to a pizza so the
comedy store mitzi shore right
yeah misty shore had this uh accountant
for
35 years named michael and for like 20
years she wanted to fire him but
couldn't get the
have the heart to do it he had hip
surgery and when he was in surgery
she fired him that's a true story right
this business is yeah and he got when he
got out he's like i don't have a job you
know me so it was like kick them when
they're down yeah yeah so that's what
distefano pulled the mitsy shore anjanus
oh my lord that is cray-cray
it seems crazy because i was supposed to
do rogan when he was still on youtube
then i got coveted and i got so sick we
had to postpone it
and then i did rogan and then we broke
up right after i did rogan
all right so you get out of kothen i get
our covenant quarantine right you're
about to do rogan yeah
right you find out that without any
you know warning this stefano
just had started a new podcast with sal
he's making out with someone else yeah
you see you found out about it
in your heart let me ask you something
right now yeah when you first found out
about it
right did did you cry no i didn't i
thought it was fine
i think the fans were a little confused
i think some of our fans were a little
confused
um and then so then did you confront him
about the sound thing
no all right so how does that work he
just calls you out of nowhere and goes
we're done
no no he didn't no no okay
you're good you're interrogating me good
he's good at asking the questions yeah
he's not good at picking up information
and the answers
right right he's giving a lot more
answers than you think right
i know i understand it right but for our
viewers out there and people listening
right they can't read his like you know
facial expression
you're interpreting so i'm just trying
to you know this a good i think a good
way to
that that will satisfy you okay good he
likes to do a lot of things
he likes to do a lot of things i like to
do one i like to focus on one thing and
bring it to fruition
[Music]
and he also got a tv show too so that
and then he had to commit to la for
three months so
things were kind of it almost seems when
we look back
now it almost seems like ah maybe that
was meant to happen because he had to go
to la for three months
he wanted he did another part he was
looking you know maybe it was just
different vi
you know how many years did you do the
podcast with that uh
almost three we did three years almost
three hours how many episodes
um i would have to check that yeah
hundreds now
yeah but if you include uh patreon
content yeah
they're patreon oh yeah i saw
because i i want to say this for the
record um
i want to say this for them all the rest
of it was off the record no that's still
on the okay
this is more on the right or on the
record i want to say
that um when you guys did our podcast
back in the apartment right no right
here in the next door oh you did it here
yeah right so when you guys did it there
um and um i didn't know you that well
and um and i'm gonna be i'm
i'm getting emotional no i am
i'm speaking from my heart okay um
i had an epiphany when we were sitting
there when you guys came over because i
thought
oh that's why people are listening
because of that guy
giannis because of janna simon
you know paul simon i thought that's a
songwriter
and that's the heartbeat of the thing
you know so it's like
and then um all of a sudden you know and
then
you know your partner chris gave try to
murder my friend with kovid
by bringing a mexican over to her you
know yeah and that his race has nothing
to do with by the way
yeah has nothing to do with by the way
all right and i love your people
he's spanish whatever yeah he's
the same literature from galicia yeah
same same
um uh dna yeah same dna
say well not really because mexican is
like a lot native and then a spanish
blessing
can we just move on they're both human
can we [ __ ] move on from this
sensitive topic
i'm not mexican or spanish so remember
so here's i'm getting emotional again uh
okay so what i'm saying is is that when
i found out of the breakup it broke me
but you know what
i believe giannis that you have a bright
future ahead of you
thank you um i will because of my
loyalty to you
yes um chris will not do our podcast
while he's here in l.a by doing
are we canceling we're canceling him
well he's booked into
that i was curious to hear what you were
doing wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
let me ask you something right now
because i don't know who's coming up
i know you don't but
just let me let me finish my train of
thought right because this is a big
decision now
right so that guy's coming in two weeks
or in a couple weeks
in a couple of weeks when i get okay so
you could do both though no no no no no
no no no no i
have to it's about loyalty my friend
right it's about um
bonds blood bonds right um cancel it
you have to cancel is that the call i
don't want you to do that i want you to
treat him fight for him
what is this giannis fight for christ
fight for him to be on the spot he's
fight for him he is a
funny okay
yeah you know that yeah yeah he is
a handsome guy right you know that he
likes your legs though
for a comic yeah yeah for a comic he's a
very handsome guy
and he's done every other podcast you
don't be the only one left out
no that's not no no it's like no that's
not it that's not it
you know it's like i like guests
honestly i like guests
that don't do it often like i'm trying
to call people
because i know that my friend baron
holtz doesn't really do it
you know jordan peel we've had on and
and that's like a thing that
genius i'm proud of because it's like
you know no one else got
could get jordan you know i mean so it's
like i want people on our podcast that
nobody else can get so
i feel like chris d is a podcast [ __ ]
you know and he's [ __ ] everybody and
wow why would i feel special i'll think
about
having chris on i think you should have
him on how's the baby
the baby's amazing i don't trust her yet
but she's amazing what do you mean
i just don't know her that well yeah she
hasn't done anything for me
i know hey guys we're gonna take a
really quick break to share some of our
favorite sponsors with you
for hymns hymns hymns andreas you have
to use it
you've heard us talking about hymns and
how they are helping guys look
their best and if you haven't it's time
to see what they're all about guys
guys